ellen degeneres and the stars weighing
in on her daytime controversy
we just know from our time on the show
that we had lots of laughs you know we
enjoyed ourselves on the show
i don't think anyone knows what goes on
you know behind the curtains except for
the staff the people who work there and
the people who know
so you know i guess we just know hard
for us to comment
on it yeah yeah hoda kodpi and jenna
bush hager who co-host the third hour of
the today show
were cautious about what they said about
ellen but early
this morning katy perry came roaring to
ellen's defense
the singer mentioned ellen's fight for
equality and wrote she had
only ever had positive takeaways from
her time with ellen
kevin hart shared this pic saying i
stand by the ones that i know
and that i love et has learned there are
still plans to start shooting the new
season of the ellen show
next month meanwhile hoda and jenna just
reunited in person on the set of the
today show
a week ago of course you are taking
procedures to keep
the crew safe yourselves safe i mean
case in point you got that prop desk
right there
a good old six feet apart what else are
you guys doing to stay safe on set well
they well they take
when we walk in the door they have
temperature checks right away
and you get a wristband when you walk
into 30 rock like that's just how it
starts
they're doing coveted testing often
we're pretty rigid
around here for sure i mean i've been
really impressed with how
everybody's handled it work may be back
on track but hoda's still trying to
figure out her wedding plans with fiance
joel schiffman
the pandemic forced them to postpone
their ideas and rethink a destination
wedding
we haven't picked our new date we're
just waiting to see what is what
with everything and you know look it's
just like
the show i don't care where we do it as
long as we do it
so are you looking to maybe speed things
up because of the pandemic and just kind
of doing it in new york city making your
destination in the city
you know what i was thinking of actually
probably slowing it down because i think
i don't think anyone could get here hoda
and jenna are also dealing with another
postponement
the olympics so they've created their
own summer games
we gotta talk about this highly
competitive game that's going on this
week
the hoda gen olympics we've got
somersaults we've got splits
we've got cartwheels you guys probably
have to be pretty sore now huh
well the track and field portion was
tough
i mean it's fun to be able to to laugh
yeah you know i feel like
most important i mean we know we don't
look that great
we look terrible